I lied about all this for probably like 6 months. Okay. But he's
just lying. He's like a lazy, lying, disgusting
pervert, disgusting weirdo. The logo of the server is a skull
that has the letters CPS written on it. Yes. These people have
a hyperbolic time chamber to analyze all of the content that's
happening and to snark all of it, okay?
>> What a day. What a day it is. Is it not an auspicious
day? Is it not?
You please just explain the situation. Okay, so there is a clipping
Discord that I'm a part of, okay? It's been there for a while.
I have substances in it. Um Couple people here are in it. Right?
And we post Basically, I will ask for links to stuff. Uh I will
suggest clips to people. I'll retweet other people's clips. Right?
And there's a bunch of community or there's a bunch of creators
in there. And that's what I use that for is I just use it to
go over clips, to retweet clips. It's like and and talk about
content. Like it's talking about content and sharing opinions.
Hey, what's your opinion on this drama? What do you think about
this? Giving an argument, right? And calling everything snark
is so disingenuous. Yeah. So this is Discord. It's like um semi-private.
I don't know how you'd quite talk about it. It's like semi-private.
It's around 100 people. It's invite-only.
I know that it's going to be public eventually, so I talk in
there like I will be
I will be offensive in there. I will say offensive things.
But overall, it's really nothing, right? Anyway, so there's a
bunch of creators in there and yeah, we talk about [__]
We laugh. We have a good time. And basically, they're trying
to post like cut up logs with absent any context as if this is
like an evil doxing server. Destiny wants this to go and flow
into his greater narrative that I'm running like a cabal that's
been working against him that hates him and wants to undermine
everything he's ever done.
All right, maybe we start off with the spider Twitter. We'll
go through some of these clips.
It's like Lunar Box clips on here. There's also spider like leaking
these logs from this Discord. I might have to go to some Hutch
thing. I do want to get this I want to get this out cuz Hutch
lied about something specifically.
And I don't know why he did this.
I really I don't. I don't know well, sorry. At least from what
I could tell it seems like he lied. And that was basically when
he tried to paint the Discord as as people who are
as soon as as soon as people or Hutch tried to paint this Discord
as someone that was like talking about his sister who is passed
away and like on her or like trying to [__] on him
because of his sister or Uh that's where it got weird for me
or at least I can't see anything in there that is anything like
this. I would totally shut that down. Like I obviously don't
like collateral attacks at all. I always shut that stuff down.
So he painted it that way and
I like I feel like I have to show people what the logs are around
it. What do you put up here? Got to say I'm not terribly surprised
to have found this in the leak snark Discord logs. Folks, this
is online politics. If you're invoking dead family members of
this stuff, you're years overdue for extensive therapy, delete
your accounts, and reevaluate.
I don't know what the context of this was. If I saw somebody
say this around me, I'd be like you're a psycho, you're like
crazy, you're I like what the [__] is wrong with
you? You know what I'm saying?
But the conversation I can find in the
is this one. But basically I can read it off. Somebody was like
making a video about Hutch and it's like this is the conversation
around it. Thinking about whether or not to include a mention
of Hutch's sister passing away and the effect it had on his on
him and it feels like I should. It seems like it was a big turning
point in his life and led to him getting his diagnosis. 7:05
in the video and he posts some video of Hutch talking about his
bipolar diagnosis. And then the person says, "And he talked about
it with Dr. K a lot about dealing with it and it was a big change."
there's apparently a joking poll that says, "Should Tony's Should
Should this guy snark Hutch's dead sister?"
And it's all no. So, like that that sounds like a joke, but immediately
the responses to it are, "Hey, no no no, I don't think you should
mention this or or like joke about it at all." Right? And the
guy's like, "Yeah, I don't want to joke about it at all. I'm
not joking about it at all. Like, it's just important. I would
I wouldn't snark her. I would just mention it as a dark time
in his life in the biography section."
And the person says, "Maybe let Hutch speak for himself on how
it affected him." And he's like, "Yeah, I was thinking of including
a short clip or two about him talking about it and how he felt
how he felt afterwards." So, like to me, I'm like, "That's tasteful.
It's like not even
That's not even like it's literally just somebody talking about
they wanted to make a video on Hutch. And they're like, "Oh,
for like leading into who Hutch is, uh this is how I I would
frame it or this is I think it's important. I don't think it's
something I leave out."
It was never about attacking her or anything like that.
So, I don't know where this is from. I've not seen this.
But, it's totally absent context
Okay. Anyway, all right. I'll show those I'll show those chat
messages in just a little bit. We just need to redact them
Did someone brought it up in the live and learn chat like coordinating,
I believe. I haven't gone back and listened to his stream again,
though. Does he have proof of that? Cuz from what I what I heard,
and I haven't seen logs of this, but from what I heard, someone
asked Someone was actually annoyed about it and I think they
asked if anybody in that Discord was doing it and everybody said
no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, I'm saying that I've seen no proof that
anyone in that Discord would do that.
In fact, I think most people are not fans of that.
could there be like a who did it on some alt account and then
lied? I don't know how to control for that. No, I don't I I hope
not. I make it very clear this kind of [__] is not
cool.
Right? Like there is a there is a mean nature to some of the
the commentary.
There's a mean nature to it. I'm not I'm not going to lie to
you guys. Like it's it's mean. It's like mean girl like snarky
commentary. Just like you'd expect on some snark subreddit or
people talking [__] on Twitter or anywhere, right?
It's mean.
But essentially what this is all going to boil down to is these
people are being really mean about me. That's what this all is.
These people are like really mean. Oh.
Okay. Pearl clutching is no carry anymore. What's this Yeah,
that's all it was was pearl clutching. They're all just like
oh, these people are really These people are really mean and
they have like They spend all their time doing this. You ain't
got a hobby, man? Imagine not having passion for anything and
then decrying and degrading denigrating other people's passion.
You don't got any You got any any hobbies that you're passionate
about, man?
My hobby happens to be
watching low IQ political streamers and laughing at them and
calling them stupid in a Discord. That's my hobby, man. I don't
know what am I supposed to do?
It's Is it a healthy hobby? Is it a bleeding of more productive
society?
Nah. Nah, it's not. It's not.
>> But it is it is fun and it actually
not even arguably, it absolutely helps me with my job. Like I
just Dude, you have no idea how much it helps when I've just
watched like a bunch of adjacent content to something and it
just informs me telling a story.
Right? It's just It's like required to tell a story.
All right, let's watch this clip of Dan and Mouton on anything
else.
Ethan Klein is the number one person they hate in there. The
number two person they This is Dan talking about this Discord,
okay? Now, as with any Discord, could there be somebody who does
something really wrong, really bad,
and needs to be punished for that, right? Like, we have there's
there's an absolute no doxing rule. There's like a bunch there
the rules are enforced. The only person I know of who had done
doxing stuff in
was banned.
This clip is funny to me because we talk about a bunch of different
drama and stuff in there. And Destiny's presenting this is like
evidence of the cabal against him. The cabal that's pro-Hasan
and against him,
And it turns out Destiny's not even the most not even in the
most top the top three most snark people in the server. Like,
the people who get talked about the most, Destiny's not even
in the top three, according to Dan.
It's so funny, man. Ethan Klein is the number one person they
hate in there. The number two person Ethan Klein, number one.
they hate in there is Nicholas DeOrio. Do you want to Number
two is Nicholas DeOrio. Oh, okay. The third person they hate
in there? You. Who It's Destiny, right? Cuz it's the cabal against
Destiny.
s-
trans
streamer I've never heard of called TransFirebat.
I have no There's a dedicate So, if you don't know, this is something
of an inside joke on that server. Is there a people who care
about this tiny creator who feuds with Purple Perry Gaming, right?
And
the joke is the the like I think
me and Kweebman have at least a couple times made a comment something
along the lines of like, "Bro, are you guys serious with the
like with with this call with this TransFirebat call? Like, are
you are you serious right now?" There was one time like some
big content had gone down and nobody had like talked about it,
nobody had saved the streams, nobody had done anything. It's
just like, "Bro, why are there 50 clips of this stupid person
with 20 viewers and you guys aren't YOU GUYS AREN'T GOING AND
DOING anything about it. It's so dumb. I I've personally advocated
multiple times for the people talking about this person or this
drama to be banned from the Discord. Not on any like moral grounds,
not on anything like saying it's wrong because I don't want to
see
Off with this stupid person. I don't care. I don't care.
I'm not like against people watching some creator
but holy [__] Off, I don't want to see it. It's so
boring. It's so stupid.
The idea of Dan sifting through gigabytes and gigabytes of transfirebat
like archive streams or commentary on their stream. Like that
is dude, yeah, he's in the [__] coal mines right
now. Dan Dan has been banished to the coal mines. He's going
to have to look through all of those. What the What are they
talking about? What are they talking about? Dude.
Yeah, it's going to be funny, man. It's going to be Anyway, so
I just want to point out that Destiny is not even hated enough
by this server to be more talked about than transfirebat. It's
not
It's not Dan. It's not Hutch. It's transfirebat.
trans
streamer I've never heard of called transfirebat.
I have no They There is a dedicated
like gangstalking operation for this I I've never even heard
of this person before and these I I'm not even joke I'm you're
looking at me saying who and that's I thought that I was losing
my mind cuz I saw firebat. I was like, we talking about Starcraft
here? Is this code name of something? That's how [__]
crazy it is. Yeah, they'll be like Wow. >> I don't know.
I don't think it's it's not the it's not the Hearthstone guy.
I looked at that also. I don't it's not firebat the Hearthstone
guy. It's literally like I can't find [__] about
this person. It's just like some Dan RACKING HIS BRAIN TRYING
TO find trans fire bad content. Oh my god. Nobody trans person
that they're all obsessed with a logging and harassing. It's
kind of crazy. It's uh it's very weird and creepy. I Post the
logs of me advocating for all of those people to be banned cuz
they waste my time. I'm Like it's to the point where I'm like,
okay, Claude is acting up uh as I go through this. It's It can't
be that many messages about this person. It's weird. It's very
weird. It's a very, very weird. They're very, very weird people.
They're very obsessive. They're very They're stalkers.
That's the thing you have to know is that this this server it's
not based around from what I've seen so far. It's not based around
activism. It's not based around doing anything good or having
a positive influence. They don't Wait, what? What do you mean?
What do you mean it's not based around having a positive
I What How are you arguing
This guy is trying to Dan Saltman is personally making it his
mission to with Abdullah Sayid. That's what his personal mission
is, okay? So much so that he wrote a an article in the Free Press
about him. All right? That's Dan's mission right now.
Let's keep going.
We'll watch This is all of them talking about the same Discord,
okay? Multiple streams from Hutch, Lonerbox, Connor, Destiny,
all talking about this same stream. Oh, Dan and Mr. Mouton all
talk about the same
like Clipper Discord and people being mean in it, okay?
Lonerbox jokes about selling the
files amid ongoing drama. They're not a fan of like Destiny or
Dan or whatever. So, I was like, okay, wait, wait. Actually,
maybe it turns out I do have a kind of unique access here. Then
I thought, wait.
Let's think about this. There are These people have upset a lot
of very wealthy individuals. So, I just put out some feelers
yesterday, you know? I was like, "Okay, who are the wealthiest
people I know that these guys really don't like and these people
are talking?" So, I kind of went through, you know, it was
I'm trying to make peace with Lonerbox, so I'm not going to go
in on him very much today. But, this is a kind of psychotic thing
to do, no?
Like, I thought he was joking.
Did he actually put out feelers or is this just a joke? Maybe
it's just a joke. Maybe after the clip he says it's just a joke
or something. This would be totally psychotic if this is what
he's actually >> saying. Usual suspects, you know, your
Dans, your Ethans. You know, I messaged I messaged Destiny as
well. I was like, "Hey brother, listen. I know we've had our
differences, but uh some He's got to be joking. >> times,
you know, uh mutual uh mutual
wink wink. And, you know, I thought I would like make them make
them feel like they were the only ones getting these messages,
you know, a bit of manipulation. And, uh you know, there's uh
turns out there was a highest bidder. Um you can guess who. So,
I'm sitting on a solid 20k right now. I don't know what I'll
do with it. Maybe go on holiday somewhere, some type of [__]
Uh it's out of my hands though, you know? Good good luck.
I feel like this
is like obviously a joke to me.
No, I said I literally said I don't know if this is true. I assume
it's a joke. If it's not a joke, everything I think about Lonerbox
is wrong.
Uh what's the punchline? So, when I say joke, maybe I shouldn't
say joke.
I think Lonerbox feels personally slighted, and so he's saying
this to try to inspire fear or or angst in the people who have
who have slighted him, who have upset him. And, this isn't like
a sincere expression of intent or of action, but something that
you do like in a petty fashion out of spite to make people worried
that you're you're helping their
You know what I mean? That's so not a joke, just not sincere.
Right? When he said he messaged Destiny about it, I'm like, "No,
you didn't." I I'm pretty confident you didn't. Pretty
I [laughter] In other news, uh okay, no, actually I all the I
guess all the people who messaged me last night with something
to say about this whole
I mean, you've given me a lot to think about. That's that's nice.
Uh
I think somebody offered him money and he's joking about that.
Yeah, he's coming back. Yeah, yeah. He's not saying he sold anything.
He was he was basically doing a bit.
whoever is giving it to me is giving it to other people. Cuz
it's it's pretty straight straightforward. There's not much I
can do. I kind of wonder, would Luna be at all
that not just
I I hope he would be worried or think about the idea
that he could have possibly been given something specifically
to upset him, to turn him against people.
Right? That the person who is the third party has been leaking
him stuff might not be leaking everything to him first. I hope
he thought about this.
Just saying. In a general sense.
Not really my thing. I don't fancy >> Okay, well. Okay,
this is the next one. What is this clip? Let's answer for it.
Let's take a look. >> be way less likely to
to [clears throat] be like now I'm just
Now I'm just suspicious. So like
it's going to be
I'm going to be way less likely to engage in in this kind of
like
attempts at manipulation. I sent
kind of like troll chatters, some people call them snarkers.
They usually hang out in the like the J stock, Queenman, sometimes
in peace ghost community. They show up here every now and then.
They show up in soy pills. Like what is going on with your life
if you're hyper focused
on, you know, like
small to mid-size
like politics streamers.
Is that
Oh, sorry. Ethan Klein, Nicholas Yorio, trans fire bat. Maybe
The funny thing here is, to be honest
To be honest with you, um it's very funny to me cuz in my opinion
in my opinion
Hutch just underestimates how creepy and obsessed people can
be. Like, he's not in the top three according to whatever AI
Dan used. He's not in the top three. And dude, this I swear to
god Hutch's entire stream this morning or the parts I watched
are There's a There's a group of people who are surveilling me.
They're watching all of my streams. There's like 12 people watching
all of my streams. And then it's like, Hutch is live to 450 viewers
right now. I don't know if you know this, but there's more than
12 people watching all of your streams. There's way more than
12 actually.
They like watch my streams and read my tweets and it's crazy.
Okay. I don't All right. That's
Dude, imagine the paint guy at Home Hardware. He's like, this
person brought me a bucket. Uh they brought me a swatch and they
said between these two colors. And then
I had to make them paint
with the color that was between those two. It's like you're describing
your job. Yeah, that's your job is people watch you and then
they comment on your
KJ Stahli is different than the people who watch me disagree
and dislike me. No, it's not.
No, it's not. Everybody's got people who watch their content
and dislike them. Hutch knows this by virtue of the fact that
he obviously caters to that exact crowd of people who focus on
Hasan.
I'm not going to say that Hutch is as creepy or weird as some
of the people in this discord. But he absolutely caters to the
creepy weirdos who are just like that for
Know that, okay? There are a bunch of people in Hasan's chat
or sorry, in Hutch's chat who are the same kind of obsessed creepy,
weirdos, and he he's just coping about it, okay?
Like for me, I'm not watching every Hutch stream. I'm not watching
every moment of every Hutch stream. I I pretty strictly ask for
timestamps of Hutch Hutch streams, to be honest with
I I ain't ain't nobody got time for that. This guy goes on a
lot of side tangents, man. Okay. All right. So, creepy and weird,
creepy and weird, creepy and weird. What's this one? Destiny
has the group logs going back 2 from the group Luna box was talking
about. I've lied about this for like 6 months. Let's see. >> One
thing a lot of them have in common is that a lot of them have
tried their hand at creating at some point and just not done
very well at it. Like they're kind of failures. Connor said that
just a little bit ago was in his DMs today using his divorce
as an opportunity to suck up to him. That's pretty weird and
cringe. But, okay.
I don't think Connor would have characterized the DMs that way.
I don't think so. Here's what I said to Connor. Hold on. I'm
going to I'm going to leak my Connor DMs right now.
I don't think Connor would even have a problem with me leaking
it, given that characterization. I'm going to leak my DMs to
Connor right now. These are the DMs.
Hey man, I covered your latest stream, and although I was making
I'm making jokes about stuff during it, I'm genuinely sorry to
hear about the split. Hope stuff is as good as it can be. Okay.
Hey, I did a stream. I was joking about you. I was laughing at
you. I was laughing at your pain. But, I hope you're doing good
anyway.
Is that me sucking up to him? Is that not just like a pretty
normal human thing? Hey, my job is to like watch content in this
space and to laugh at it. I did that with your pain.
I've done it with a lot of other people's pain, and they don't
even get the courtesy of a message. There's honestly a point
in that stream where I I couldn't make a comment cuz Connor was
describing some interpersonal stuff that I was like was very
sad to hear. And that made me think like, "Hey, I'm going to
let him know, hey, that's like I'm sorry this is happening, man."
Yeah, I'm just Okay.
Sucking up. What the What the Okay, uh we keep going. >> to
like Connor said that just a little bit ago was in his DMs today
using his divorce as an opportunity to suck up to him. That's
pretty weird and cringe. The final boss is unemployment. There's
like this whole
There's this whole uh Uh And a maybe have a common thread amongst
them. Like a lot of them are One thing a lot of them have in
common is that a lot of them have tried their hand at creating
at some point and just not done very well at it. Like they're
kind of failures. And a lot of them also seem to share this one
thing in common that they've discovered >> Okay, never
mind. I'm sorry. Okay, you know what actually it hold on. I'm
sorry. Okay. >> I lied about all this for probably like
6 months. Okay. >> It's here. The master plan is about
to unfold. Okay, this was yesterday I think. The master plan
is about to unfold guys. >> One of the big huge drops of
my manifesto is that I've had a person who is in the server that
learner box is going to talk about who has been logging the entire
server for the better part of the last two years. Every single
thing that Justical that Kilo and that every other piece of [__]
that's been in the server that's been coordinating tweets, coordinating
docs, coordinating harassment, coordinating YouTube videos. Every
single one of them has been for By the way,
he says I believe he says last two years to make it seem like
it covers his like court case or something.
It doesn't.
It's not It's flat out not existed for two years. Not even Not
even one year I don't think.
So, I think he's trying to make it seem like this could cover
his court case and
like explain this cabal narrative he came up with to dox people
with. But he's just lying. He's like a lazy lying
pervert, disgusting weirdo. So, he's just lying. He's just lying.
Very
Think about it. Every single one of them is trying to scurry
around Ethan posted about the doc server, did he? Somebody link
something about it. Hold on. That'll be it. I'll have a huge
like search for index of this after my manifesto. Okay, sorry.
These people everybody been seduced by this once every few months.
Hassan will repost this and boost this motif. That's kind of
a thing. Um, but I got I don't really I don't really know if
any character like read the [__] that I'm given for.
So, I don't know what I'm talking about. Like I don't really
stuff like this down I'm not interested in me. Although some
of the stuff that I've done has been fascinating. Um, the second
one I'll say is going on for a while and the the two phases of
this um, one question I have that I got like if you want to make
a video could you make this fine. Um, I would be curious why
they would use sulfur as like their research director though.
Uh, that was a little bit jarring to me because if because I
remember quite well. Sulfur if you guys remember used to be a
moderator in the community. You can consider them Bro, these
people have [__] up so badly. Suddenly hear chatter
of a secret snark Discord that's being leaked. I wonder who they've
spent the past two years obsessing over. We are obsessed with
such a with such a with a person like you. Such a whiny,
worthless, spineless, [__] loser, okay? We are very
obsessed, yes. Everybody is obsessed with Ethan Klein, yes. The
logo of the server is a skull that has the letters CPS written
on it, yes.
A dude.
I'm just I'm just telling you
They're They're making this sound so cool and so awesome. And
then they're trying to be like, "These guys are unemployed."
Okay, and? We We just That's how passionate people
All right? It's awesome. It's awesome. I love that I can show
up and
I can be like, "Hey,
did somebody watch Hutch's stream And a hundred of the hundred
of the most maniacal, funniest,
just raise their hands and go, "Yeah, we all watched it today.
Yep, we got all the timestamps. Yeah, we watch all of it. Yep."
Every single time Every single time hundred hundred people raise
their hands. "Yeah, we watched the entire
Yeah, did you watch the H3 podcast, too? Yes. These people have
a hyperbolic time chamber to analyze all of the content that's
happening
and to snark all of it, okay? We are in This is the hyperbolic
time chamber. All content will be analyzed. Everything you say
and do will be analyzed. It will be recorded and we will laugh
about it. I'm sorry to tell you.
It's happening.
It's been happening, okay? Anyway, I Uh this should be very funny
that Ethan Klein's blowing the server up right now. Very cool.
The best time FOR SNARK IS NOW.
It is now, yes. Oh boy. Hutch is so gross for swinging his dead
sister around, man.
I'm just I I can basically show people when that when stuff like
that gets said, like I push back on stuff like that if it gets
said. Guys, don't know I don't know what to tell other people,
man. Dude, okay. We're going to be featured on the H3 podcast.
I hope I got some bangers.
We'll see. We'll see what happens. Do you consider that your
I don't know what that sentence means. She was demoted.
For reasons we've been over a few times. Oh, we need the we need
the L if we need it. What's happening? One of the reasons she
left was because I had called her out. I didn't name her, but
I just got to know. I called her out because she had called me
quite strongly to falsely accuse someone of this harassment.
She had produced this whole like 50-page document because she
does that. She like overwhelms people with information or like
she's got her own like her whole thing in this Discord was like
to plan arguments. And as soon as she was losing, she would just
tell people to read the reason why a lot of them are scurrying
now there's a whole bunch of weird battle lines. I'll go over
all of this when I drop my manifesto hopefully in 3 weeks or
whatever. just messed up this stupid case. But like they do so
it's so cringe. Like Substance will workshop these tweets with
like just a goal of like Doobie and these other Seba and the
I don't even remember their [__] names. I'm just
like Byplane I don't remember their names. They're just random
losers. But like they workshop these tweets together. They'll
post the tweet. They tell everybody to like go and retweet and
engage with and juice it up. They'll give talking points to each
other in these Discords and then
every one of my viewers is like, "Oh, so he's doing that to another
space. So he's actually like being a terrorist in forcing other
spaces to do this, too?" Yes. Everywhere I have control over,
I will ban you if you don't juice my tweets. You, okay? This
is not a democracy. I'm a dictator. Juice the tweet. Juice the
tweet now. Dude, people are complaining about that on Twitter
the other day. They're like, "Jidion linked the Keemstar video?"
And he he locked the Discord so that people would engage with
it. Everyone of my Discords like, "Thank you for finally pointing
this out. He's been doing it to us for years." Yes, I do do that.
Yes, I do that all the time.
And they'll go out and debate like other people. It's the level
of like coordination is insane. It's unhinged. How crazy I think
what Luna Bots is talking Dude, the level of the level of coordination
is is crazy. It's unhinged. It's It's unhinged. Guys, YOU HAVE
NO
how unhinged and crazy it is. >> They'll post the tweet.
They tell everybody to like go and retweet and engage with and
juice it up. They'll give talking points to each other in these
Discords and then they'll go out and they'll debate like other
people. It's the level of like
So hold on. You know what? Actually, let's just slow that down
and and let's slow that down and remove the
cult spin, okay? Let's just slow it down and remove the cult
spin. Maybe this is what we should do. We should be the the no
spin zone, okay?
I don't I don't remember the answers. They're just random losers.
But like they work out these tweets together. They'll post the
They go, "Hey,
what do you guys think of this? Do you guys think Do you think
this would pop off?" There's a bunch of creators in there, a
bunch of people who are on Twitter, a bunch of people who are
streamers. They go, "Hey, does this sound like funny?"
Evil. Absolutely evil. We They tell everybody to like go and
retweet and engage with and juice it. They post a tweet and say
juice the
Absolutely evil. Can't think of anybody else who's ever done
that. Surely we won't find a bunch of examples of Destiny posting
his tweets for his community to go and juice, right?
Surely not. Um Look, they're talking points to each other in
these Discords and then they'll They'll give talking points to
each other in these Discords. They'll argue about content with
each other in a group of friendly people with a shared interest,
okay? All right. All right. They'll go out and they'll debate.
Does it watch your stream, by the way? Yeah, that is my thing.
Juice the tweet. Juice the tweet. Juice the tweet. Juice the
tweet. Yes. together in these Discords and then they'll go out
and they'll debate like other people. It's the level of like
Then they'll go out and debate other people.
They like standing on business and standing by their ideas.
Imagine that. Imagine just being like, "Yes, this is what I believe.
I will argue with people." Imagine that, man. At which was literally
on stream crying about not having more motion on one of his anti-Hassan
tweets at J Stalk. Oh, that's so cool. Oh my god.
DGG, please. I'm not getting enough motion on my tweets.
Okay? I mean, that's Listen,
that's normal human interaction. I don't know why we're trying
to take normal It's because they're inhuman. It's because Destiny
doesn't understand what it's like to have friends or like a common
interest with other people. He's basically just operating on
himself or operating by himself, and he's like a psycho who doesn't
have real meaningful
And so, when he sees other people working together, he applies
like a Machiavellian lens to it, which is inappropriate, right?
That's not what anyone's We're just having fun, man. We're just
having fun.
And Destiny's like, "They're like trying to destroy my life."
Bro, they don't even talk about you. Well, sorry, they do talk
about him in there, but you're not one of the most talked about
people in there.
It's just a bunch of people having fun, doing what they enjoy.
Why you got to be a hater, man?
Snarking is legal, okay? Snarking is legal. Having negative opinions
of Destiny, or Ethan Klein, or Nicholas De Orio, or any of these
losers is totally legal. If you can point to illegal or even
immoral activity beyond just being mean to you, go ahead.
We don't want that, right? We The only person who's ever done
anything close to doxing that server, or so who's ever done like
actual doxing, like revealing private info of somebody,
was banned.
What else is there? I'm trying to think of like other people
who've been banned. I I try to police the like tone, to be honest
with you,
I'm not very successful sometimes. Anyway, it's It's like not
a problem, though. And I've never told people not to say like
people snark on me in there. Bro, there's some guy in there who
calls me a a maple monkey every time he's in chat and I'm in
chat, he calls me a maple monkey.
Am I supposed to WHY ARE YOU SNARKING ON ME? BAN THIS GUY NOW.
BAN THIS GUY RIGHT
NO. I don't Dude, it is what it is. It is what it is, man. What
am I supposed to freak out and be like, "Oh my god, BAN THIS
GET HIM OUT OF HERE. He's mean to me."
You If you WERE MY FRIENDS, YOU WOULD BAN this guy. IF YOU WERE
MY FRIENDS, YOU'D DELETE this guy's messages. If you were my
friend, you wouldn't let this
I literally talk about other people all the time.
I Why Why would I say you can't talk [__] about other
people? Coordination is insane. It's unhinged. How crazy. And
I think what Lunar Box is talking about is So, these people like
obsessively start writing these huge manifestos and then they
try to gaslight Not gaslight. They try to amplify and gas up
all these toxic people that are that they perceive amplify and
gas Dude, amplify gaslight gaslight amplify amplify gaslight
juice it up Look at talking points to each other in these Discords
and then they'll go out and they'll debate like other people.
It's the level of like coordination is insane. It's unhinged.
Talking to your friends is insane and unhinged. Okay. How crazy.
And I think what Lunar Box is talking about is So, these people
like obsessively start writing these huge manifestos and then
they try to gaslight They obsessively start writing these huge
manifestos.
They obsessively start writing these huge manifestos. Is this
like My Wand trying to put together the Beast video into a video
cuz she has a personal
Like somebody else did a whole bunch of
Dude, by the way, this guy didn't even write his Keppels manifesto.
It was like everybody else writing that entire Keppels manifesto
with a 10-person group chat or a 12-person group chat. How in
the world does he Dude, it's so fake. It's such a fake allegation.
They all lined up and uh thought it was awesome when he did the
Keppels manifesto with a group chat behind him who were helping
him write it the whole time. Who he works By the way, I know
for a fact that this lazy This lazy
workshops his tweets in the A-team group chat. I know he does
cuz I've seen people ask about it. I've seen people comment on
it.
Why is he pretending he doesn't know what this [__]
is? Why is he pretending that this any different?
So, they did it to Dev a while ago where they were constantly
focused on Dev short SFO short fat otaku and then they've done
it with um uh they've
do it with people who are against us. Dev is just a liar. Dev
is just a weird liar. Like Why are you Why would you stand on
this? Why would you just stand on the time Dev lies and he transparently
is like unwilling to admit that he was lying and he lies more
and he doubles down and he lies and he lies and he lies. Dude,
I didn't I didn't start pirate software because he was like against
Hassan or against Destiny or I can't remember where my I can't
remember like
I can't remember who Destiny would say I was against at that
time, okay? I did it because he kept doubling down and lying
the whole time. Double down, lie, lie, double down, lie, double
down, lie, double down.
If Dev's going to do the same thing, I'm going to follow that
and laugh at him. Sorry. They're doing a little bit with Luna
box now even though a lot of these people like aren't even in
my orbit or whatever, but they're they're just cuz they haven't
made statements that are strong enough against me or that they're
still too anti-Hassan or whatever. Um,
Like some like Yeah, I know Maple Monkey is funny. That's why
I like
no problems with that, okay? It's no problems with that.
It's a snark community, okay? People be snarking. Important announcement,
spider, please lend me your ears. Insane coordination alert.
What is this? Oh, sorry, this is a this is somebody who's on
my team, so to
Insane coordination alert. This guy's in two different chats
at the same time. Oh my god. Oh my god.
INSANE COORDINATION IT'S INSANE HOW coordinated these people
are all over the place. They're all over the place. Oh my god.
>> The funniest part is when they talk about having like
coordination, when they talk about this concept of they watch
streams
Um, hello, DGG chat?
Guys,
guys, it's so disgusting how these people coordinate and they
like watch a stream together and they snark on the person. Anyway,
I'm winning, guys, let's go. Embed Hassan NOW, LET'S WATCH HASSAN.
LET'S SNARK HASSAN. Let's Let's anal gaze every move and talk
about him all the time. Be totally obsessed. Wow.
It's almost like Destiny getting a taste of his own medicine.
Destiny getting a taste of what other creators get from DGG,
which is, by the way, totally legal, totally allowed. But now
that you're under that same lens, you're freaking the [__]
out. You're tearing your hair out. Why is that, man? Destiny
Destiny looks in the mirror and he he abhors what he sees, okay?
What is this creature that stares back at me? That's he doesn't
like it. He doesn't like having the mirror held up, okay?
All right. Hutch asked Loadedbox for the internal server logs.
So, I believe Hutch went on and asked Loadedbox >> article
that some one of my friends put up on Substack. I'm like, okay,
big big
But then obviously like
I saw their notes for how they were producing this video and
saw the kind of arguments that they were making or some of the
comments they were having on my stream as they were watching
it um from me talking about the issue and I just thought it was
like very kind of funny and how flagrantly dishonest and poorly
like argued it was. So, yeah, I just commented on that yesterday
and also yesterday I got sent like the full logs of the uh the
server from this
turncoat, I guess.
Oh my god. And yeah, I just mentioned that as well. And now it's
I guess it's been a bit of a big life event for these
Wait, can you send me the logs? Can I get the logs? Uh
I'll have to ask my mole, okay? I mean, I've seen some pretty
Have you named any names? Are there Is there anybody in there
that I that is like familiar to me? Uh yeah. Oh, I have to see
these logs, dude. I have to see them. I have to like listen and
tell your mom so I'm so
about this kind of stuff. I would never ever ever I won't even
I won't even put it on my work computer.
Yeah, okay. So, listen, I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
pull up a big list here, okay? And there's a list of all the
people who have asked me for more information about the server
and access to these logs, okay? There's a huge queue forming
up. I'm I'm starting to I Yesterday I was thinking I should actually
start taking bids, you know? My allegiance is to the highest
bidder. And then I found out Destiny already has them, so now
I'm annoyed.
But you know, you know. I'm sure that given what I've seen, there
are definitely some people who would pay a who would not pay
for a penny for that, you know, like Ethan >> This is before
the wild logs, by the way. Dan Saltman and the wild logs and
assuming Destiny doesn't show it to Dan for some whatever reason.
So, Okay, anyway, Destiny has the logs and Hutch asked for them.
Okay.
We watched this one? Yeah, we watched this one. We're going up
to them now. Okay. So, here's another one. We'll we'll explain
all of these or we'll we'll look through all of them, So, man,
imagine shooting yourself in the foot this hard. Turning private
community drama into doxing allegations, dragging unrelated stream
streamers into it, brigading other streamer chats, and having
screenshots where the apparent focus is taking talking about
other creators and logging them while somehow expecting to come
out looking good. Genuinely incredible self-sabotage.
Uh no, nobody thinks like anyone here is going to look good.
All we want is for you to admit that you don't care about like
the truth about, you know, the truth of what's being said at
all. You're just mad cuz people are are being mean to you.
So, no unethical conduct.
Right? So, that when people get mad, when they get asked mad
about this, their only argument boils down to, "You're being
mean to me." That's the goal, okay? So, that the output of the
server is not affected. Okay? As Queenman say, "Okay, I'm going
to be real." Left would have been banned after Perry's covered
in Acandros. I'm going to lose it if Perry versus Kathy versus
Ricky, whatever, keeps coming up.
And this is basically trying to hit Queenman, right? Wait, so
the chat got purged. Someone please resend the preserve tube
link to run right back. It's not just Cole, it's literally everyone
shooting themselves in the foot repeatedly and everyone involved
should be totally ashamed. Guess what? Internal community doxing
drama looks terrible on everyone. So, how about don't be a Oh,
can't say that word. Send IP sending IP grabbers and don't blow
it up on six streams when you've been palling around with the
guy doing it for a year. Well, I So, what Dude, I don't know
what the underlying drama is here. Like, I'm pretty unaware.
But, I know that Queen Man's saying you guys can't do this. So,
I'll give you what I think it is. I think it was like somebody
in this server as a joke had as a joke They're saying as a joke,
which I think a lot of people believe is a joke. Okay? Even I
think the people who were in the servers where it happened believe
it was a joke until they basically got in a fight. But, he sent
a link that was like there's some website you can put you could
It's like a short URL thing that records the IP of anybody who
clicks on And I think he sent something like that in one of these
chats or in one of these Discords. Not in this Discord, in a
different Discord. Nothing was ever done with it. I don't think
anything ever happened. But, what Queen Man's saying there is,
"Hey, it looks bad when you guys have these kinds of fights cuz
then it like basically makes it look like there's a crazy [__]
going on in here when there's not. But, it makes it like other
people with bad intentions who are not going to treat you with
good faith, who don't understand you at all could possibly paint
it that way."
The The fact is is like if you want to be in that Discord, don't
make jokes like that or you could just go.
Like, it would be my opinion, too. If you're going to make a
joke like that, [__] off. Don't be around.
Like, we're we're clipping. We're like actually, you know, in
this thing trying to make like content happen. Trying to make
awesome content happen. And you're doing in like a in like a
10 like a five-viewer streamer's Discord, you're posting a link
like this that could look bad. Like, [__] off.
Don't do it.
There anyone that was really obsessed with Ethan Klein? I mean,
Kathy doesn't like Ethan Klein.
Kathy That's Kathy's the person who snarks Ethan Klein like the
most. Kathy doesn't like Ethan Klein. But, we love We love Kathy.
We love Kathy. Well,
sometimes. Kathy can be funny. Kathy is unreliable sometimes,
okay?
Little little unreliable sometimes.
Did you run the video through your local synagogue? I made it
anti-semite proof. You're criticizing Of course, he'll call it
anti-semitic. And this is being framed as good faith criticism?
How Wait, how would it not be good faith
How does a joke from the creator of the
about Ethan Klein's propensity to call everything anti-semitism
because he is a like histrionic loser, how does that have anything
to do
with the good faith criticism, bad faith
Taking the ADL. Oh god, spider
roast. What is wrong with Spider-Man? Why would you do this?
You tagged the ADL? Uh-huh, okay. At Charlie Kirk 11, okay, that's
funny. I didn't say spider was smart. I did not say spider was
I did not say that. I've never once said that. I would absolutely
never say that,
I said I thought he was better than this. I thought he had a
good heart.
I This is not a good heart. It's a tainted heart, okay?
So, this is another out of context log. You don't see anything
around it, right? And this in and of itself, Ethan Klein objectively
by it by any measure outside of like an ADL's like the ADL
Ethan Klein over accuses people of anti-semitism. He turns a
lot of the critiques of him into anti-semitism. He always wonders
if people are being anti-semitic. This is just a joke.
Holy [__]
Hutch reacts to Lonerbox calling out Mod Sulfur over pushing
false dude. Calls her out. Hold on. Hold on. Hold >> I
didn't name her. He's going to make a
Yeah, he's just going to make a face at the camera. He used this
whole like 50-page document >> Dude, it's going to be so
easy.
To any remotely neutral third party, this guy is like a total
[snorts]
I just I love Listen, it's like Stardust, Hutch, Spider,
Dan, Destiny, Willy Mac.
Oh my god.
Dude, all Oh, we've got I'm I'm Dude, can I find the tweet? Where's
the tweet? Where's the tweet?
judge me. Judge me by my enemies. Judge me by my enemies, guys.
Wick, yeah, Wick. My god.
I think Wick was posting about how like, "Oh, it's so obvious
these guys were doing crazy the whole time." Okay, can tell you
haven't seen anything.
All right. I think this is the last one we need to watch to really
dig into today, okay? I think this is the last one that's very
important to get into.
This is the big smear that pissed everybody off. I think we're
like
I wanted to like slow play this and let them talk about stuff,
but this is the big smear that if this had happened while I was
awake, I would have said, "No. No, these guys." Like we're going
to we're going to actually start responding cuz holy [__]
So, this smear was gross to me that Shmoo and Nikacado are both
like big up-and-coming YouTubers. Nikacado's Shmoo, Nikacado.
And to try to like derail them or or accuse them of doxxing when
it's really not doxxing what's going on here at all,
it's just goofy, okay?
caught using doxxing tools to unmask anonymous X users in the
Snark Discord. Wick logs, this didn't happen. Spider is illiterate.
Wick logs show discussion of using doxxing tools. Uh this is
true that there was some I think Nikacado mentions a tool here.
Tracking username history and trying to pressure anonymous accounts
into revealing personal information before the conversation moved
to private channels. Anyone know how to do how to gay off them
into revealing more info? Run the doxx tool. Let's see. Let's
see. Let's see. Context Redacted is a Twitter account that Shmoo
came across and wants to know the identity of. They only they
suspect it of being a Tectone one of Tectone's alts or a mod.
Other unrelated names are redacted as well. Doxx tool one and
doxx tool two are websites to find the personal personally identifiable
information on it by on any username. You can receive things
such as past usernames, real name, address, email, breach passwords,
photos, and other
Nikandros posts a picture. That redacted guy is 100% someone's
alt or something.
So, basically what I think Shemuel and Nikandros are talking
about here and
What's what this accusation is implicitly trying to do is it's
trying to discredit people
for like by making illegitimate
And as a consequence,
right? As a consequence, how is Hutch gross? He's a lying, manipulative,
disgusting loser who is not willing to show any grace to his
friends in the same way they show grace to him.
I find that disgusting personally. And I can prove this very
easily. We're not going to do it today, but I can prove very
easily.
Anyway, we keep reading. So, they want to use this smear to go
after Nikandros and Shemuel, essentially, effectively protecting
TechTone. They're trying to smear these two people who are saying,
"Hey, we want to make sure that Pink here has evidence for her
What is it? Her protective order, right? To maintain her protective
order, to possibly
like some kind of violation. Now, I can't imagine What What kind
of space do you guys think it would be that they're going to
really get upset about trying to find basically if this guy's
a TechTone mod and to pass that on to a victim of a crime, to
pass that on to a like a assault victim. What kind of What kind
of space is like, "Oh, oh we hate We hate the other people in
this space so much that we're going to take these two who are
just trying to help out somebody who was a victim of
And we're going to try to degrade them, to denigrate them, to
smear them, to go after them. Anyway, we keep reading. They're
They're trying to protect TechTone. They're trying to undermine,
I guess, Pink and they're going after these two to do it. Let's
Let's actually look at what the allegation is. Let's look what's
actually happening here. That redacted guy's 100% someone's alt
or something. Techy?
I don't know who, but that uh unrelated redacted person is in
redacted state and is personal friends with Tectone.
Related redacted. And they also hate unrelated redacted.
Okay, so what? This is Pink and then unrelated redacted is in
redacted state.
Anyone know how to gay up them into revealing more info? It could
just be a personal friend of Tectone as well, but definitely
something going on definitely something going on there. I'm not
sure his viewers even know he's friends with unrelated redacted
or not.
Anyone know how to gay up them into revealing more info? It could
be a personal friend to Tectone as well, but definitely something
going on there. I'm not sure his viewers even know he's friends
with unrelated redacted or not. So this is Novaru, okay? Uh Tectone
is way too obsessed not to do something like this. Language analysis
stat. Mr. Mr. would indicate they're male.
What was the name of the account? So they're trying to figure
out if this is somebody related to Tectone. So basically they're
bunch of people who are participating in a coordinated smear
against Pinky Cheeks. Like there were creators talking about
how Tectone was sending them documents and stuff. Right? And
that is against the protective order. And so I think what they're
looking for is evidence of that happening again. Any evidence
of
of like Tectone reaching out to third parties, which he's not
allowed to do, to give them info on Pinky Cheeks so that they
can disparage her. That is against the protective order.
Against it. And so they're they're thinking Nikacros has a hunch
that this is somebody related. Uh there's no redacted on Steam.
I guess it's the the name of the person they're looking at. Could
be be unique enough to look it up through this thing. That person
might be enough to have another account
Uh redacted image one. Clumsy attempt at woke scolding? No, it's
just So they're pondering this person's identity.
this could this does seem like a little odd to me. You're like
asking about this person randomly. But is it like is it doxxing?
No. Um maybe So, Nikandros is pretty comfortable looking up like
stuff like this, I guess. But, that's cuz he's had to like he
he makes videos, right? So, he'll investigate stuff like this.
He's pretty not afraid to just say like, "Yeah, I'll look stuff
up." He's very very very careful about what he's revealed. I
don't believe there's any credible allegation of Nikandros doxing
anybody. He is incredibly
incredibly careful with any information he's going to publicize.
So, you can say this looks weird, but I would say with the track
record that Nikandros has built over multiple videos of never
revealing info, of actually reaching out to people and letting
them know that they're giving too much info away. He has He basically
has a track record of doing this. That if he's like investigating
people, he'd give them a heads-up like, "Hey, just so you know,
you've got like a bunch of data out here and like I'm not doing
anything with it. I promise I'll never reveal it, but you need
to do something about this."
Okay? So, I just think when he's got that track record, I'm not
as I personally feel like I'm not as concerned about him, you
know, talking about this. I would prefer he didn't do it in a
like 100% Discord, right? But, it's like it's like maybe a bad
look in some way.
Okay, anyway.
Okay, clumsy attempt at woke scolding. Redacted image, redacted
image. Could just be one of his mods, I guess, his followers.
From my POV, this redacted guy is some [__] who wanted
who watched my video and seemed to agree with that. I doubt it's
him. Yeah, it's most likely the most likely thing is it's a mod
or something, but I guess it specifically follows Pink just to
do [__] like this. They had two username changes,
run the blank docs tool, too. These are like We'll get more information
on this from the chat conversation, all right? Uh also, these
memes they post fake plastic That's Freud tongue, a Freudian
slip. A Freudian slip. File that away for later. 100% Freud.
So, he's saying this is probably a Who the [__] even
knows what the names of these girls are? Spectate is already
zoned the the in, noticed them calling Rev a sweet person.
I don't know who that is. Um, this guy's Twitter ID is redacted,
so finding whatever their account's old username was, chat messages
from Nick Fuentes and Shmu now move to voice or direct messages
with public chats from them ending completely at this point.
Okay, so this allegation is essentially there's nobody doxed
here, right? What they're trying to do is they they're trying
to see if they can connect this to another person that's connected
to
And but connected through a pseudonym to Techtone, right? They're
trying to see would this be another Twitter user, would this
be another person like with a pseudonym? And if that pseudonym
has like an identity, then that could be if you published it
doxing. I think if you connect like a a public identity to a
private one, that is a form of doxing. Now, with any form of
doxing, there is like there is obviously the Taylor Lorenz example's
a good one. I didn't get a chance to highlight it this morning,
but I think Dan was talking about how some of these people support
Taylor Lorenz and she doxed Libs of TikTok. There's a public
interest argument for doxing. Libs of TikTok was doxing and harassing
and calling for multiple people to be fired. I believe they got
people fired from their jobs. Right? Libs of TikTok was a serial
doxer.
That is why it's in the public interest to know the identity
of Libs of TikTok. Now, the bar for finding out if they're a
serial harasser is high. With Libs of TikTok, they admitted to
it. They said they did it. The way DG Yid here, this is like,
oh, so you think defensive doxing is a thing? Well, you have
to prove the person was doxing. Right? You can't just you can't
just
say they doxed somebody and then dox
like you can't you can't totally fabricate a self-defense incident.
Say, oh, this person may be threatened when they were facing
the other direction, right? And then shoot them in the back and
go, "Ha, that was self-defense. No, I have a I have proof of
a conspiracy that this guy was talking to somebody who was talking
to somebody who was talking to somebody who was going to shoot
me."
It was self-defense. That doesn't work,